Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. What Hitler did was advertise unoriginal ideas in an original way. He gave voice to phobias, prejudice and resentment as no one else could. Others could say the same thing but make no impact at all. It was less what he said than how he said it that counted. Welcome to The Rest Is History. We are with Sir Ian Kershaw talking about Hitler and this obviously is Hitler Part Two. So hello Tom, looking forward to a bit more Hitler? I'm always looking forward to a bit more Hitler
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。希特勒所做的，是以一种原创的方式去宣传那些毫无新意的观点。他将恐惧、偏见和怨恨表达得淋漓尽致，无人能及。其他人或许也能说出同样的话，却无法产生任何影响。重要的不在于他说了什么，而在于他如何去说。欢迎收听《历史的余味》。我们今天与伊恩·克肖爵士（Sir Ian Kershaw）一起探讨希特勒，这显然是希特勒系列的第二部分。那么，你好，汤姆，期待更多关于希特勒的内容吗？我一直都很期待更多关于希特勒的内容。
and not least because really in Part One, you know, there was so much we covered. There was so much fascinating stuff that Sir Ian was giving us. There were his powers of oratory, the root of his hatred of the Jewish people, actually even the nature of evil. So this isn't a podcast just about Hitler. This is a podcast about incredibly broad themes, the kind of themes that contemplating Hitler almost inevitably provokes. And we barely made it out of the 1920s. So if you missed that first episode, please do make sure you go back and find it before you listen to this one. Although hopefully you already know how the story is going to end. Yes. So we were talking last time about Hitler's rhetoric and his sort of superpower, as it were, if that's not too trite a way of putting it, being his demagoguery.
尤其是因为在第一部分中，我们确实涵盖了太多内容。伊恩爵士为我们提供了许多引人入胜的素材。比如他的演说能力、他对犹太民族仇恨的根源，甚至是对邪恶本质的探讨。所以，这不仅仅是一档关于希特勒的播客，更是一档探讨极其宏大主题的播客，这些主题几乎是思考希特勒时不可避免会引发的。而且我们当时才讲到20世纪20年代。所以，如果你错过了第一集，请务必在听这一集之前回去找来听听。尽管希望你已经知道这个故事的结局了。是的。所以我们上次谈到了希特勒的修辞，以及他那种所谓的“超能力”——如果这样说不算太陈词滥调的话——那就是他的煽动术。
And I think that takes us back into our next question to Syrians. So, Tom, it wasn't just words, was it, that Hitler used to impose his will on the German people? No. The methods that Hitler employs and the Nazis around him are, I mean, well, they're described by his critics as criminal. They employ thuggery, violence, blackmail. Do you think that, does Hitler think of himself as being criminal? Is he conscious of this strain of criminality within him? Or is he wholly convinced of his own rectitude throughout? He's convinced of his own rectitude throughout? He's convinced of his own rectitude, that it's in a just cause.
我想这把我们带回了给伊恩爵士的下一个问题。那么，汤姆，希特勒用来将他的意志强加给德国人民的，不仅仅是言语，对吧？不。希特勒和他身边的纳粹所采用的方法，我的意思是，被他的批评者描述为犯罪。他们使用暴行、暴力和勒索。你认为，希特勒认为自己是罪犯吗？他是否意识到自己身上这种犯罪的倾向？还是说他始终坚信自己是正义的？他始终坚信自己是正义的吗？他坚信自己是正义的，认为自己是在为正义的事业而战。
He recognises, of course, that he's engaged in activities which are regarded as criminal. After all, he was sent to jail for a short period of time in 1922 for the thuggery of his supporters in a beer hall brawl and let out on promise of good behaviour, which of course he reneged on in 1923. So these things were seen as criminal at the time. It wasn't just that people were subsequently seen as criminal. But Hitler saw them, he saw the real criminals he always spoke about uh from the early 1920s always spoke about the november criminals these were the people in his view who brought
当然，他意识到自己参与的活动被视为犯罪。毕竟，他在1922年曾因支持者在啤酒馆斗殴中的暴行而入狱服刑了一小段时间，并以保证表现良好为条件获释，当然他在1923年就违背了这一承诺。所以这些行为在当时就被视为犯罪。这不仅仅是后来人们才将其视为犯罪。希特勒本人也看到了，他总是谈论真正的罪犯，从20世纪20年代初开始，他总是谈论“十一月罪犯”，在他看来，这些人引发了
about the revolution of 1918 and the destruction of of the german nation and he saws uh central to that that a bunch of so-called november criminals jew Jews. So for Hitler, action which was served at attacking the real criminals, as he saw it, was a matter of rectitude, of political rectitude. And so after the failed putsch attempt in 1923, he took pride in standing before the court where he was arraigned of high treason and was responsible for it because this was actually defending Germany supporting Germany upholding German interests against the real criminals of these November criminals so he saw himself as serving
1918年的革命，摧毁了德国民族，他认为这其中的核心就是一群所谓的“十一月罪犯”——犹太人。因此，对希特勒而言，攻击他眼中那些真正罪犯的行为，是一种正义，是政治上的正义。所以，在1923年政变失败后，他为自己站在法庭上接受叛国罪审判而感到自豪，并对此负责，因为这实际上是在捍卫德国、支持德国、维护德国利益，对抗那些真正的罪犯——“十一月罪犯”。所以他认为自己始终是在为
a purpose of rectitude throughout including of course later on as well so there wasn't a question in Hitler's mind that he was doing something that was wrong or evil. He was doing something in his own mind that was right. And Hitler's, throughout this period, the Nazis, as Tom says, there's a lot of thuggery, there were the stormtroopers and stuff. Violence is part of their ethos throughout this whole period. Is that, do you think, for Hitler, is that a product of the First World War?
正义的目的服务，当然也包括后来。因此，希特勒心中从未怀疑过自己所做的是错误或邪恶的。在他自己的心目中，他所做的是正确的事。而且，正如汤姆所说，在这一时期，纳粹充斥着暴行，有冲锋队之类的组织。暴力贯穿了他们整个时期的精神内核。你认为，对于希特勒来说，这是第一次世界大战的产物吗？
Has he been desensitized to violence by his experience in the trenches? Because he's not a violent man before 1914 and not someone who particularly, as far as I'm aware, talks about violence or revels in violence. So do you think that's part of this sort of wider story or is there any psychological reason why he particularly could be so inured to the costs of violence? Violence was not just confined to Germany, of course, in the period immediately following the First World War. a level of brutalisation or insensitivity to violence is something that historians have utilised as an explanation for the behaviour of people drawn to fascist movements in different countries in the immediate period after the First World War. And certainly the First World War, the violence of the First World War
他是否因为在战壕中的经历而对暴力变得麻木了？因为在1914年之前，他并不是一个暴力的人，据我所知，他也不是一个特别谈论暴力或沉溺于暴力的人。所以你认为这是更宏大故事的一部分吗？还是说有什么心理原因导致他特别能够忍受暴力的代价？当然，在第一次世界大战后的紧接着的那段时期，暴力并不仅仅局限于德国。历史学家们利用“残暴化”或“对暴力不敏感”这一概念，来解释第一次世界大战后各国被吸引到法西斯运动中的人们的行为。毫无疑问，第一次世界大战，那场战争的暴力
helped to inculcate a readiness in many people then to accept violence, which had not been part of anything to anything like this extent of society in most parts of Europe. Some parts that were very violent before the First World War, but in Western Europe, certainly the levels of violence were new. And Hitler was part of this general trend. So it's not a matter of just for Hitler personally, but for many other people too. We see that now there's a readiness to accept the correctness, to use Tom's point previously, of violence to bring about political aims in a way that hadn't been
促使许多人产生了一种接受暴力的准备，这在欧洲大部分地区之前的社会中从未达到过这种程度。有些地区在第一次世界大战前就很暴力，但在西欧，这种暴力程度是前所未有的。希特勒是这一普遍趋势的一部分。所以这不仅仅是希特勒个人的问题，对许多其他人来说也是如此。我们现在看到，人们有一种准备去接受——用汤姆之前的观点——通过暴力来实现政治目标的正确性，这在以前是
there before and Hitler is part of that trend in the early 1920s. And the ability to use violence, the ability to menace people, you know you've talked about this is his great talent, his ability to sniff out weakness and to strike when opportunity presents. The converse of that, I guess, is also that it might have gone wrong, that circumstances might have worked out very differently. And how close does Hitler come to failing completely? Quite close, in particular with the putsch, of course, in November 1923. And when he was on trial um in april 1924 he was sentenced to a very lenient few months in jail and then even let out early although he shouldn't have been given his previous offense he should have been kept in there but um that was the point where he
不存在的。希特勒是20世纪20年代这一趋势的一部分。而使用暴力的能力，威胁他人的能力，你知道你谈到过这是他伟大的天赋，他嗅出弱点并在机会出现时进行打击的能力。我想，反过来说，这也可能出错，情况可能完全不同。希特勒离彻底失败有多近？非常近，特别是在1923年11月的政变中。当他在1924年4月受审时，他被判处了非常轻的几个月监禁，甚至还提前获释，尽管考虑到他之前的罪行，他不应该被提前释放，他本应被关在里面，但那是他
it comes closest to failure probably and where he um uh it could have it could have been expelled from germany even he wasn't a german citizen at the time he was still an austrian um uh he uh that was a point where he had actually failed and yet the leniency of bavarian justice let him off the hook and allowed him then to rebuild his own party after he came out of prematurely let out of jail. And as I said before, while he was in prison, he was very, very comfortable in prison. He had lots of visitors. He was, his own image was built up while he was in there.
最接近失败的时刻，他甚至可能被驱逐出德国，当时他甚至还不是德国公民，他还是奥地利人。那是他实际上已经失败的时刻，然而巴伐利亚司法系统的宽容让他逃脱了惩罚，并允许他在提前出狱后重建自己的党。正如我之前所说，当他在监狱里时，他过得非常非常舒适。他有很多访客。当他在里面的时候，他自己的形象得到了提升。
So that was a big moment of near failure. There were others as well, just point to one, the end of 1932, where on the verge of him becoming Chancellor of Germany, he, with the Nazi Party, divided and in a mess. The second most important leader of the Nazi Party, Gregor Strasser, wanted then to go into government as the vice chancellor of a nationalist government, and Hitler refused point blank.
所以那是一个接近失败的重要时刻。还有其他时刻，仅举一例，1932年底，在他即将成为德国总理的前夕，纳粹党内部四分五裂，陷入混乱。纳粹党第二重要的领导人格雷戈尔·斯特拉瑟（Gregor Strasser）当时想作为民族主义政府的副总理进入政府，而希特勒断然拒绝。
It was a moment there where the party could potentially have fallen apart, but Hitler did, as he did so often, he appealed to the loyalty of those around him, they rallied to him, they turned on Strasser, and eventually Hitler was still left there as leader of a party. And a few weeks later, he was made Chancellor of Germany. But that was another moment where potentially things could have gone very wrong. And then, as you say, just a few weeks later, he becomes Chancellor of Germany. He's famously, you know, manoeuvred into office by the sort of internal machinations of the kind of nationalists and the right and stuff, the conservatives around Hindenburg, who think they're using this Austrian corporal and then
那一刻，该党本有可能分崩离析，但希特勒像他经常做的那样，呼吁周围人的忠诚，他们团结在他身边，转而攻击斯特拉瑟，最终希特勒仍然是党的领导人。几周后，他被任命为德国总理。但那是另一个事情可能完全出错的时刻。然后，正如你所说，仅仅几周后，他就成为了德国总理。众所周知，他被那些民族主义者、右翼分子以及兴登堡周围的保守派内部的阴谋诡计所操纵，他们认为自己在利用这个奥地利下士，然后
they'll discard him. And then he accumulates more and more power. And yet, I remember reading your biography 20 years ago and being so struck by what was to me a revelation because I didn't know much about it, how useless Hitler was as a kind of administrator, as the head of a government. You know, he's lazy, he gets up late, he gives the impression of somebody you can't trust to do his paperwork, all this kind of stuff. And I guess the question is, I mean,
就会抛弃他。然后他积累了越来越多的权力。然而，我记得20年前读你的传记时，被一个对我来说是启示的内容所震撼，因为我对此了解不多，那就是希特勒作为行政管理者、作为政府首脑是多么无能。你知道，他很懒，起得很晚，给人一种你不能信任他去处理文书工作的感觉，诸如此类。我想问题是，我的意思是，
you have a concept in your book of people kind of working towards the Fuhrer, of people imagining what Hitler wants and imagining kind of some radical idea and trying to deliver it. But was there a point, were there moments where people high up in the Nazi high command or in the administrative machine where they thought, you know, the Fuhrer is a bit of a dead loss. He is, you know, sleeping in all morning and, you know, he's a bit weird and this sort of...
你的书中有一个概念，即人们“朝着元首工作”（working towards the Fuhrer），即人们想象希特勒想要什么，想象出某种激进的想法并试图实现它。但是，有没有一个时刻，在纳粹高层或行政机器中，有人想过，你知道，元首简直是个废物。他整天睡到大中午，而且他有点古怪，这种……
Or did that just never seem to dawn on them at all? Well, I don't think if it dawned on them, they were very careful to keep quiet about it, I think. But you have to remember, of course, this was a very sophisticated modern state with a top civil service who could carry out things, who could anticipate actions in certain ways. They didn't just wait for directives to come down from Hitler, but they were preparing things. So they were, he laid down guidelines. You couldn't actually do something which went against, directly against those guys. You couldn't come along in 1937 or 38 and say, well, basically, I think Jews are a good thing and why don't we actually promote that?
还是说他们根本就没意识到这一点？嗯，我不认为如果他们意识到了，他们会小心翼翼地保持沉默。但我认为你必须记住，这是一个非常复杂的现代国家，拥有顶级的公务员队伍，他们可以执行任务，可以在某些方面预见行动。他们不仅仅是等待希特勒下达指令，他们还在准备事情。所以，他制定了指导方针。你实际上不能做违背、直接违背这些方针的事情。你不能在1937年或38年跑过来说，嗯，基本上，我认为犹太人是件好事，我们为什么不推广它呢？
I mean, these were things that were unthinkable. So as long as you had to follow the guidelines, there was a lot of room and scope for imaginative development there on the part of civil servants and many others, and military too. Hitler was doing things that the vast majority of military leaders actually wanted. So of course, some of them had cold feet about a war against the Western powers. But in general terms, what Hitler was doing was building up the armed forces and so on. So not until things went wrong later in the war, then there was no great antagonism there either. And so in all this, you have a leadership
我的意思是，这些事情是不可想象的。所以只要你必须遵循指导方针，公务员和许多其他人，包括军方，在创造性发展方面就有很大的空间和余地。希特勒所做的事情正是绝大多数军事领导人实际上想要的。所以当然，他们中的一些人对与西方大国开战感到胆怯，但总的来说，希特勒所做的是建立武装力量等等。所以直到战争后期情况恶化之前，那里也没有什么大的对抗。所以在这所有的一切中，你拥有一个领导层
which is representing things that many parts of that regime actually want and go along with. It wasn't actually, so the fact that he wasn't a bureaucratically efficient didn't really make much of a difference for most of the time. And of course, in the key decisions on foreign policy, and then when it came down to it on anti-Semitism and so on, Hitler did make these decisions. So there wasn't a notion that he was actually just feeble and not interested in things. He would take interest in it and act when it was necessary. And otherwise, things ticked along in the way that he wanted them to go. So what are the qualities that he brings to his chancellorship that enable him to become a success? A lot of it was this setting the tone, setting the directives, and then letting
它代表了该政权许多部分实际上想要并随之而行的东西。所以，他不是一个官僚效率高的人，这在大多数时间里并没有产生太大的影响。当然，在外交政策的关键决策上，以及后来在反犹太主义等方面，希特勒确实做出了这些决定。所以不存在他实际上只是虚弱、对事情不感兴趣的说法。他会对此产生兴趣，并在必要时采取行动。否则，事情就会按照他想要的方向发展。那么，他为自己的总理职位带来了哪些品质，使他能够取得成功？很大程度上是这种设定基调、设定指令，然后让
the forces then mobilize themselves. So it didn't actually micromanage, but rather unleashed forces, which were already in many ways pent up there. There was pent up economic demand following the Great Depression, for example. He set the motor industry going. It didn't need to do any more then. You've got people in the motor industry who are only too anxious then to build it up. You've got the military going. So he unleashed a lot of forces from within that were very happy to move in the direction that
力量自行动员起来。所以他实际上并没有微观管理，而是释放了已经在许多方面被压抑的力量。例如，大萧条后有被压抑的经济需求。他启动了汽车工业。之后就不需要再做什么了。你拥有汽车工业中那些急于建立它的人。你拥有军队。所以他从内部释放了许多非常乐意朝着他想要的方向前进的力量。
he wanted them to go in. And then, of course, he had a whole series of successes, seen from the point of view of most Germans at the time, successes in the economy was already going to rebound from the Great Depression anyway, but he was fortunate enough to be on the, at the time, the timing of that meant that he presided over that rebuilding. And everybody noticed how well things were going economically after this, that the rebuilding was taking place. There was a lot of activity. In terms of foreign policy, a number of big successes then already in the early 1930s, and you had the Western leaders coming to his door and taking notes of him.
然后，当然，他取得了一系列成功，从当时大多数德国人的角度来看，经济上的成功无论如何都会从大萧条中反弹，但他很幸运，当时的时机意味着他主持了那次重建。每个人都注意到经济重建后情况有多好，重建正在发生。有很多活动。在外交政策方面，20世纪30年代初已经取得了一些重大成功，西方领导人来到他的门口并对他表示关注。
Germany was back on the scene. And then from 1936, a succession of major foreign policy successes, German militarisation was again a major factor in this. So Hitler seemed to be very successful. And as long as he was successful, people were prepared to grant him more or less what he wanted. So he didn't need to do more than, I say, it sounds a bit puny when I put it that way, because of course, decisions like the Rhineland and so on, they were big political decisions.
德国回到了舞台上。从1936年开始，一系列重大的外交政策成功，德国的军事化再次成为其中的一个主要因素。所以希特勒似乎非常成功。只要他成功，人们就准备给予他或多或少他想要的东西。所以他不需要做更多的事情，我说，当我这样说时听起来有点微不足道，因为当然，像莱茵兰等决定，它们是重大的政治决定。
But Hitler set the tone, set the directives, and then freed up these resources and unleashed the pent-up resources, which were all ready to go, and which then acted in the ways that were moving along in the direction that Hitler himself wanted. And this may sound an odd question because it runs counter to our knowledge of how history actually worked out. But is there a world in which the Nazi dictatorship could have become stable and could have become sort of, as it were, de-radicalized. So, you know, people love to do these sort of man-in-the-high-castle type fantasies of a world in which the Nazis win the Second World War. What does a Nazi Europe look like in the 1950s or 1960s?
但希特勒设定了基调，设定了指令，然后释放了这些资源，释放了被压抑的资源，这些资源都准备好了，然后以朝着希特勒自己想要的方向移动的方式行动。这听起来可能是一个奇怪的问题，因为它违背了我们对历史实际运作方式的了解。但是，是否存在一个纳粹独裁统治可能变得稳定，并可能变得，怎么说呢，去激进化（de-radicalized）的世界？所以，你知道，人们喜欢做这些《高堡奇人》式的幻想，幻想一个纳粹赢得第二次世界大战的世界。1950年代或1960年代的纳粹欧洲是什么样子的？
Is that world imaginable? Is a world in which Adolf Hitler leads a German government that has just become sort of almost, I mean, this would sound an extraordinary thing to say, but almost a kind of small C conservative, steady as she goes government? Or was there an inbuilt ratchet always towards greater radicalisation, towards, you know, ever more sort of eye catching coups and gambles and so on? In the Nazism that we actually know, down to 1945, there was no stopping the aim of radicalisation. And after all, in genocidal politics, it didn't stop with the Holocaust at all. But the SS were working out plans in 1942, or as they called the General Plan for the East, which anticipated the removal, i.e. killing, of around 30 million people over about the next 25 years.
那个世界可以想象吗？是否存在一个阿道夫·希特勒领导的德国政府，它刚刚变得有点，我的意思是，这听起来是一个非同寻常的说法，但几乎是一种小写的“保守”，稳扎稳打的政府？还是说有一种内在的棘轮效应，总是朝着更大的激进化，朝着，你知道，越来越引人注目的政变和赌博等等方向发展？在我们实际了解的纳粹主义中，直到1945年，激进化的目标都没有停止。毕竟，在种族灭绝政治中，它根本没有在犹太人大屠杀中停止。党卫军在1942年制定了计划，或者他们称之为“东方总计划”（General Plan for the East），该计划预计在未来25年左右清除，即杀害，约3000万人。
And this demanded an extension and control of wide swathes of German territory. Now, that depended obviously upon German military victory. That military victory, that total military victory, is difficult for us really to conceive of, I think, because it meant, which you could say 1942 was a pivotal year when things were looking good for Germany, bad for other countries. And yet in 1942, you already see Germany's overextending itself in the attempt to gain the oil of the Caucasus and so on. And we already know that the Americans are building up an enormous force, much bigger than the one that actually took part in D-Day and so on, to tackle Germany eventually. So the notion of a final German victory,
这需要扩大和控制大片德国领土。现在，这显然取决于德国的军事胜利。那种军事胜利，那种彻底的军事胜利，我认为对我们来说真的很难想象，因为它意味着，你可以说1942年是一个关键的一年，当时德国情况看起来不错，对其他国家来说很糟糕。然而在1942年，你已经看到德国在试图获得高加索石油等方面过度扩张。而且我们已经知道美国正在建立一支庞大的力量，比实际参加诺曼底登陆的那支力量大得多，最终来对付德国。所以，一个最终的德国胜利的概念，
which would need to establish it, where there would be a leader after Hitler who would turn this into a steady and stable form of established government, is to me more or less unthinkable. So I can't see that that is, apart from the realms of fantasy and novelism, so I can't see that that is, apart from the realms of fantasy and novelism, so I can't see that's really was ever a realisable prospect.
这将需要建立它，在那里会有一个希特勒之后的领导人，将这变成一种稳定和确立的政府形式，对我来说几乎是不可想象的。所以我看不出那是，除了幻想和小说领域之外，所以我看不出那是，除了幻想和小说领域之外，所以我看不出那真的是一个可以实现的愿景。
And just to follow up on that, and there's no scenario in which there would not have been a major European war at the end of the 1930s or sometime later in the 1940s. So there's no scenario in which Hitler would have accepted
接着这一点说，没有任何情景下，在1930年代末或1940年代后期的某个时候，不会发生一场重大的欧洲战争。所以没有任何情景下，希特勒会接受
a more modest expansion of Germany's borders, you know, the Sudetenland or whatever, and then sort of settling down as a normal European state. That was because that didn't feature in his ideologies. Is that right? That's absolutely right. For Hitler, I think the Second World War was the unfinished business of the first. Another war had to undo the history of the first. It was apocalyptic in a sense. It had to destroy the enemies of Germany. And they weren't confined to one particular part of the globe either. They were international. They were all over. And so that war could never be limited and settled down into
对德国边界更温和的扩张，你知道，苏台德地区什么的，然后安定下来作为一个正常的欧洲国家。这是因为那没有出现在他的意识形态中。对吗？完全正确。对于希特勒，我认为第二次世界大战是第一次世界大战未竟的事业。另一场战争必须推翻第一次世界大战的历史。从某种意义上说，它是末日般的。它必须摧毁德国的敌人。而且它们也不局限于全球的某一个特定部分。它们是国际性的。它们无处不在。所以那场战争永远无法被限制并安定下来成为
just, of course, the mistake that people like Chamberlain made and thought that Hitler was actually an extreme nationalist, but nothing more. It was something more. And this was, for him and for other parts of the Nazi leadership as well, this was something that was far more than just a matter of adjusting Germany's borders. And so it could never have settled down. War was inevitable at some point, and would probably have come about under any nationalist leader, not just Hitler, but it would have been a different sort of war almost certainly. And presumably then his success fuels his ambition for more success and broadens his horizons and the scope of what he thinks he's capable of doing. And that's then what feeds into his plans for the East, and I guess specifically
只是，当然，像张伯伦这样的人所犯的错误，认为希特勒实际上是一个极端的民族主义者，但仅此而已。它是更多的东西。对于他以及纳粹领导层的其他部分来说，这不仅仅是调整德国边界的问题。所以它永远无法安定下来。战争在某个时候是不可避免的，而且很可能在任何民族主义领导人领导下都会发生，不仅仅是希特勒，但那几乎肯定会是一场不同类型的战争。那么大概他的成功助长了他对更多成功的野心，拓宽了他的视野以及他认为自己有能力做的事情的范围。而这正是他为东方计划提供动力的地方，我想特别是
for Jews, but for many other of the people that he's conquered as well. So essentially, there is no way that the process of conquest will not fuel ever more grandiose, ever more horrific ambition. Yes, I think that's absolutely correct. And also this Hitler is not just a free agent in all this, but other countries are also acting. And by 1941, he's achieved the extraordinary triumph of the defeat of France within a matter of a few weeks. And then what does he do? He immediately turns to preparing for an attack on the Soviet Union the following year. Now, this is a visionary thing for Hitler. Of course, it's ideological. But it also has strategic purpose for it because he's unable to get Britain out of here.
对于犹太人，但也对于他征服的许多其他人。所以本质上，征服的过程不可能不助长越来越宏大、越来越可怕的野心。是的，我认为那是完全正确的。而且希特勒在这所有的一切中不仅仅是一个自由行动者，其他国家也在行动。到1941年，他在几周内取得了击败法国的非凡胜利。然后他做了什么？他立即转向准备在次年进攻苏联。现在，这对希特勒来说是一件有远见的事情。当然，它是意识形态的。但它也有战略目的，因为他无法让英国退出。
What will happen if Americans come into the war? So he has to attack the Soviet Union in his own thinking then as soon as possible so the ideological and the strategic come together in that. And Joe I mean by that point you know Hitler's involved in in World War II it's become a commonplace at this point in the West that he's mad so you hear it again and again Churchill and British newspapers will say Hitler is a madman and he's surrounded by criminals. It is an interesting question, isn't it, particularly as the war reaches its later stages. Is Hitler mad or is that merely a convenient sort of get out to escape the more difficult questions about Hitler's politics? As you've put it, it's a convenient get out.
如果美国人参战会发生什么？所以他必须在自己的思考中尽快进攻苏联，所以意识形态和战略在这一点上结合在一起。乔，我的意思是到那时，你知道希特勒卷入了第二次世界大战，在西方，他疯了已经成为一种陈词滥调，所以你一次又一次地听到它，丘吉尔和英国报纸会说希特勒是一个疯子，他被罪犯包围了。这是一个有趣的问题，不是吗，特别是在战争进入后期阶段时。希特勒是疯了，还是那仅仅是一个方便的借口，以逃避关于希特勒政治的更困难的问题？正如你所说，这是一个方便的借口。
The question of madness is, you could say by maybe at the very end there in the last weeks of the war he was living on a diet of pet pills and medicines of one sort or another and then uh under the under that strain you could speak about some mental imbalance to put it mildly but uh for the most part then then, in the earlier period, there was no madness there. And it's an apologia, again. I mean, if Hitler was mad, what does it say about all the people who followed him all the time, you know, at different levels of this?
关于疯狂的问题，你可以说也许在战争的最后几周，他靠着各种药丸和药物生活，然后在那种压力下，你可以谈论一些精神失衡，说得委婉一点，但对于大部分时间，在早期阶段，那里没有疯狂。而且，这又是一种辩解。我的意思是，如果希特勒疯了，那对于所有一直追随他的人，你知道，在不同层面上，这说明了什么？
So it's not a good argument at all. And there was actually strategic sense in what he was doing, even if it was built upon this enormous gamble for world power. And even the thing that's always pointed out, the ultimate moment of madness, which is then the declaration of war on the USA in December 1941. There was a strategic aim, but it was a move of desperation, it's true, was a strategic aim in that, which was to move the war to the Pacific and to allow German U-boats to cut off the supply of materials from America to Britain. So even that move, however desperate it was, had some strategic element to it. It wasn't the move of a madman. And as I say, I think the notion that Hitler was mad is simply a way of avoiding any real analysis of the reasons why Germany got into that plight in the first place.
所以这根本不是一个好的论点。而且他所做的事情实际上有战略意义，即使它是建立在这个巨大的世界权力赌博之上的。甚至总是被指出的那件事，疯狂的终极时刻，即1941年12月对美国宣战。有一个战略目标，但这是一个绝望的举动，确实如此，其中有一个战略目标，那就是将战争转移到太平洋，并允许德国U型潜艇切断美国向英国供应物资的渠道。所以即使是那个举动，无论多么绝望，也有一些战略因素在里面。那不是一个疯子的举动。正如我所说，我认为希特勒疯了的概念仅仅是一种避免对德国最初陷入那种困境的原因进行任何真正分析的方法。
Tom, that's such an interesting point, isn't it? Because we've talked about Nero a couple of podcasts ago. And he's another character from history that people always say, oh, he was mad, like Caligula, or like any of these sort of Roman figures. So that must be quite resonant with you, that stuff about insanity and evil and used as a sort of pejorative. Well, I think that saying someone is mad, because it explains everything, explains nothing. Yeah. So absolutely, you know, you can say Germany went mad,
汤姆，那是一个非常有趣的观点，不是吗？因为我们在几期播客前谈到了尼禄。他是历史上的另一个角色，人们总是说，哦，他疯了，就像卡利古拉，或者像这些罗马人物中的任何一个。所以那些关于疯狂和邪恶，被用作一种贬义词的东西，一定与你很有共鸣。嗯，我认为说某人疯了，因为它解释了一切，却什么也没解释。是的。所以绝对，你知道，你可以说德国疯了，
but. But even that doesn't. Yeah. It's inadequate, isn't it? Which is why we need great historians to, to go beyond that. I'll tell you what it reminds me of.
但。但即使那样也不行。是的。这不够，不是吗？这就是为什么我们需要伟大的历史学家去超越这一点。我告诉你它让我想起了什么。
Actually, we talked a little bit before about Stalin in an earlier podcast. So Stalin wasn't mad. Stalin was very clever and Stalin knew exactly what he was doing. And he was ideologically driven as Hitler was. And I think that comparison is, I mean, it's obviously been made a billion times. So I've just said, just descended into historical banality as ever. Anyway, so we're going to come back after, I think we should come back after the break on that Monday note
实际上，我们在之前的播客中谈到了一点关于斯大林的内容。所以斯大林没有疯。斯大林非常聪明，斯大林非常清楚自己在做什么。他像希特勒一样受到意识形态的驱动。我认为那个比较是，我的意思是，它显然已经被做了十亿次了。所以我只是说，像往常一样陷入了历史的平庸。无论如何，我想我们应该在休息后回来，在那个周一的笔记上
and we will talk about the downfall. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. about the downfall. Hello there, Al Murray here. For live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello there, Al Murray here. I'd just like a moment of your time to make an appeal to you on behalf of the charity DKMS. I thought because you're fans of history, you might like to make some in your own personal way. DKMS run a blood stem cell donor service to help people with blood cancer. A blood stem cell donation can save someone's life or it can buy them and their family precious time. I found out about DKMS because my nephew is very ill with a childhood leukaemia,
我们将谈论垮台。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。关于垮台。你好，我是阿尔·默里（Al Murray）。如需现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，我是阿尔·默里。我只想占用你一点时间，代表慈善机构DKMS向你发出呼吁。我想因为你们是历史爱好者，你们可能想以自己的个人方式做出一些贡献。DKMS运营着一项血液干细胞捐赠服务，以帮助患有血癌的人。血液干细胞捐赠可以挽救某人的生命，或者可以为他们和他们的家人争取宝贵的时间。我发现DKMS是因为我的侄子患有严重的儿童白血病，
a bitterly cruel disease. The only known cure is a blood stem cell donation. Thanks to three donors, he is still with us. What DKMS do is very simple, yet quietly amazing. They can make you into a lifesaver in waiting. Here's how. Go to their website www.dkms.org.uk and find out if you are eligible to donate blood stem cells. Register on their database and they will send you a swab pack. A year and a half ago when I first started campaigning for DKMS I had to explain what the swab pack was. Since Covid-19 perhaps you're all a little more familiar with it. You swab your cheeks, pop the swabs in an envelope and return them to DKMS. Then, if and when you are found to be a genetic match for someone who needs your blood stem cells, it's like a fingerprint, only more so, they will get in touch. Your blood stem cells could go
一种极其残酷的疾病。唯一已知的治疗方法是血液干细胞捐赠。多亏了三位捐赠者，他仍然和我们在一起。DKMS所做的事情非常简单，却又令人惊叹。他们可以让你成为一名待命的救命恩人。方法如下。前往他们的网站 www.dkms.org.uk，看看你是否有资格捐赠血液干细胞。在他们的数据库中注册，他们会给你寄一个拭子包。一年半前，当我第一次开始为DKMS开展活动时，我不得不解释什么是拭子包。自新冠疫情以来，也许你们都更熟悉它了。你擦拭脸颊，把拭子放进信封，然后寄回给DKMS。然后，如果且当你被发现是需要你血液干细胞的人的基因匹配者时，这就像指纹，甚至更像，他们会与你联系。你的血液干细胞可以去
anywhere in the world. You could help someone like Finlay, wherever they are. Since the pandemic, registration has fallen, and it would be great if between us, we could do something about it. Go to dkms.org.uk to see if you are eligible to donate blood stem cells. Thanks very much. welcome back to the rest is history and we are talking adolf hitler with sir ian kershaw and we've reached the later stages of the second world war things are not going well for germany um and i wonder sir ian um when do you think think Hitler realised that the game was up? I think by after Stalingrad and the retreat from the Caucasus and the defeat in North Africa, by 1943, the bombs are then hailing down on, raining down on German cities. I think by that time, he realizes that the war cannot be won in the way that he'd anticipated.
世界上的任何地方。你可以帮助像芬利（Finlay）这样的人，无论他们在哪里。自疫情以来，注册人数有所下降，如果我们之间能为此做点什么，那就太好了。前往 dkms.org.uk 查看你是否有资格捐赠血液干细胞。非常感谢。欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们正在与伊恩·克肖爵士讨论阿道夫·希特勒，我们已经到了第二次世界大战的后期阶段，德国的情况不太好，嗯，我想知道伊恩爵士，你认为希特勒什么时候意识到游戏结束了？我认为在斯大林格勒战役之后，从高加索撤退以及北非战败，到1943年，炸弹开始倾泻在德国城市上。我认为到那时，他意识到战争无法以他预期的那种方式获胜。
But the war not being won is different from the war being lost. And I think it was very late in the day when he accepted that the war was finally lost, that even as late as December 1944 with the Ardennes Offensive, what the Americans call the Battle of the Bulge. There was a last, of course, it proved out to be a vain attempt then to turn the tide. So I think there was a notion that at some point then,
但战争没有获胜与战争失败是不同的。我认为他接受战争最终失败的时间非常晚，即使到了1944年12月，阿登攻势（美国人称之为突出部战役）时。当然，最后证明那是一次徒劳的尝试，试图扭转局面。所以我认为有一种观念，在某个时候，
the West will intervene because it's obvious that you've got a very unholy alliance between the West, Western capitalism and Soviet communism. The West will intervene, see sense and come to some sort of deal. Some even talked about the Soviets doing that. But I don't think that was ever a starter for Hitler. But the notion that the West would intervene, I think was something which stayed with him for a while. And then also the idea that the Germans will get wonder weapons, which will then turn the tide, atomic bombs even. All these were, I'm sorry, didn't accept until very late on that the war was now irredeemably lost. And when it was, then it was lost completely. And then, of course, he was ready to take down the German people,
西方会干预，因为很明显，西方资本主义和苏联共产主义之间存在着非常不神圣的联盟。西方会干预，认清现实并达成某种协议。有些人甚至谈论苏联这样做。但我不认为这对希特勒来说是一个开始。但西方会干预的观念，我认为是他在一段时间内一直持有的。然后还有德国人会得到奇迹武器，这将扭转局面，甚至是原子弹。所有这些都是，对不起，直到很晚才接受战争现在已经无可救药地失败了。而当它失败时，它就彻底失败了。然后，当然，他准备带走德国人民，
the German state itself with him and said, we might go down, but we'll take down the world with us. Because that's what I find most amazing, in a way, about the last days, the last months, the last years of Hitler, is that I know that there that the assassination attempt against him, but even as the Russian forces are moving in on Berlin, even as it's evident that everything is falling to pieces, he's not abandoned. The magnetism holds. He is able to remain the Fuhrer. I mean, it just seems astonishing to me. Well, he is abandoned by increasing numbers of
德国国家本身和他一起，并说，我们可能会倒下，但我们会带走世界。因为这就是我发现关于希特勒的最后日子、最后几个月、最后几年最令人惊奇的地方，我知道有针对他的暗杀企图，但即使当俄罗斯军队进入柏林时，即使很明显一切都在分崩离析，他也没有被抛弃。磁力依然存在。他能够保持元首的地位。我的意思是，这对我来说似乎令人震惊。嗯，他被越来越多的人抛弃了
people amongst the population, but also by increasing numbers of the leaders who are looking to find their own way out. So by the end, he's got a coterie of people around him, of course, in the bunker. And some of these are very powerful and important people. But, of course, then in the end, he dismisses Goering, the second man in the Reich, from his offices in the final days in the bunker. It is things are then falling apart in monster leadership. But what you've got to remember, it's not just Hitler personally, but he has got there still until these very last days. And people like Goebbels in charge of the propaganda operation,
在民众中，但也越来越多地被那些寻求自己出路的领导人抛弃。所以到最后，他身边有一群人，当然，在掩体里。其中一些是非常强大和重要的人。但当然，最后，他在掩体里的最后几天，解除了帝国第二号人物戈林的职务。事情在怪物领导层中分崩离析。但你必须记住，不仅仅是希特勒个人，他仍然在那里，直到最后几天。像戈培尔负责宣传行动，
Bormann in charge of the party and all its repressive apparatus, Schwerer in charge of the armaments and building programme. And these are crucial figures who helped to prop up the regime right then, not least Himmler, in charge of all the police apparatus. So this is a dictatorship that has still got great strength. And the military leaders are this time, they are, having seen the failed putsch, they're wringing their hands in desperation,
鲍曼负责党及其所有镇压机构，施佩尔负责军备和建筑计划。这些是关键人物，他们帮助支撑了当时的政权，尤其是希姆莱，负责所有的警察机构。所以这是一个仍然拥有巨大力量的独裁统治。而军事领导人这次，他们，在看到政变失败后，他们在绝望中绞着手，
but they still see no way other than actually trying to follow up Hitler's orders, because what alternative do they have then? There is no way of bringing him down except through a putsch and that's failed already in July 1944. So they are condemned then really to undergo the complete destruction of Germany and go down with Hitler in a sense. But at the very end, most of the German leadership is looking for an escape in one way or another some of them by suicide but more more of them by trying to get out of it and giving themselves up to the west and then one question that's always fascinated me is you know Hitler
但他们仍然看不到除了实际尝试执行希特勒的命令之外的任何方法，因为他们还有什么选择呢？除了通过政变，没有办法推翻他，而那在1944年7月已经失败了。所以他们注定要经历德国的彻底毁灭，并在某种意义上与希特勒一起倒下。但在最后，大多数德国领导层都在以这样或那样的方式寻找逃生之路，其中一些人通过自杀，但更多的人通过试图摆脱它并向西方投降。然后一个一直让我着迷的问题是，你知道希特勒
dies the third right collapses and Germany goes through this this you know sort of dreadful period of apocalyptic period really the year zero kind of of sense at the end of the Second World War. And what do all these people think who have voted for Hitler, who've been members of the Hitler Youth, who have had Hitler's picture on the wall, who have written him fan letters? I mean, we're talking about colossal numbers of people. Of course, they've seen their world collapse around them.
死了，第三帝国崩溃了，德国经历了这段，你知道，可怕的末日时期，第二次世界大战结束时的“零点”（Year Zero）那种感觉。所有这些投票给希特勒、曾经是希特勒青年团成员、墙上挂着希特勒照片、给他写过粉丝信的人都在想什么？我的意思是，我们谈论的是庞大的人群。当然，他们看到他们的世界在他们周围崩溃。
But when you get into, I don't know, the early 50s or the mid 50s or something. So West Germany is being rebuilt from the ruins. Do they all think then that everything was Hitler's fault and he was actually a madman and a monster and, you know, they were duped? Or do some of them still deep down think, you know, the Fuhrer was right and it was a shame that it ended as it did. You know, I mean, I'm fascinated by that issue of kind of denazification because people don't tend to ditch everything they believe in overnight, do they? No.
但当你进入，我不知道，50年代初或50年代中期什么的。所以西德正在从废墟中重建。他们当时都认为一切都是希特勒的错，他实际上是一个疯子和一个怪物，你知道，他们被愚弄了？还是他们中有些人内心深处仍然认为，你知道，元首是对的，以那种方式结束是一种耻辱。你知道，我的意思是，我对那种“去纳粹化”的问题很着迷，因为人们往往不会在一夜之间抛弃他们所相信的一切，对吧？不。
And denazification was, of course, a large measure of failure. And when it was handed over to the Germans themselves to do it, it became nothing more than a farce, really. So many people did, of course, hold on to the news, but they were more quiet about expressing them now. If you look at opinion surveys, then it's remarkable in a way that already still in the early 1950s, a percentage of people,
而且去纳粹化，当然，在很大程度上是失败的。当它被移交给德国人自己去做时，它实际上变成了一场闹剧。当然，许多人确实坚持这些观点，但他们现在在表达时更加安静。如果你看民意调查，那么在某种程度上很引人注目，即使在1950年代初，一定比例的人，
it's a declining percentage, but still 10% or thereabouts still think that Hitler was a good leader for Germany and he just made a couple of mistakes. One was the war and the other was the treatment of the Jews. Minor mistakes, you might say. But so people were, and many people still thought that the actions of the people who tried to kill Hitler in July 1944 were wrong. So there were residual levels of support for Nazism at the time, and about half the population when they were asked was Nazism a good thing, a bad thing,
这是一个下降的比例，但仍然有10%左右的人仍然认为希特勒是德国的好领导人，他只是犯了几个错误。一个是战争，另一个是对犹太人的待遇。你可以说这是小错误。但是，所以人们是，而且许多人仍然认为1944年7月试图杀死希特勒的人的行为是错误的。所以当时纳粹主义仍有残留的支持水平，当被问及纳粹主义是好事、坏事，
or a good thing badly carried out, they largely said it was a good thing that was badly carried out. So prepare to blame Hitler and his other leaders too for leading them in the wrong direction. But in general terms, there was a lot of support still for the sense that not everything had been wrong that Hitler and the Nazis had tried to do. We have to say, of course, by the time you're into that,
还是好事但执行得很糟糕时，大约一半的民众主要说这是一件好事，但执行得很糟糕。所以准备责怪希特勒和他的其他领导人引导他们走向错误的方向。但总的来说，对于希特勒和纳粹试图做的事情并非一切都是错误的这种感觉，仍然有很多支持。我们必须说，当然，当你进入那个阶段时，
and maybe two other points very briefly. One is that the Adenauer government in the 1950s was doing what it could to help the collective amnesia of this period and to build up Germany by not making a big deal about the past and try to get away from the past and move forwards. And the second thing was that you had also the fact that Adenauer's policies were becoming popular,
还有两点我想简要提一下。第一，阿登纳政府在20世纪50年代尽其所能帮助国家进行集体失忆，通过不把过去当回事、试图摆脱过去并向前看，来重建德国。第二点是，阿登纳的政策当时也变得很受欢迎，
the economic miracle was taking place. And so most Germans were not intent on support, on thinking about what had gone on under Hitler. And now, by this time, was regarded as the greatest leader since Bismarck, and Hitler had faded into a residue of a very small percentage of people who would never really change their views. And slowly, I guess, or is it slowly, Hitler's reputation becomes that of the satanic figure that we talked about right at the top of the program. Is it the case that that is a process? Because another strand in Hitler's, the way that Hitler is understood, certainly beyond Germany, is that he's a ludicrous figure, that he's a comic figure with his moustache and his gesticulations and his single testicle. In fact, did Hitler only have one ball? That's, I guess, maybe the key question of the... Another legend. Another legend. No, the medical report suggests it was perfectly normal in that capacity.
经济奇迹正在发生。因此，大多数德国人并不打算支持或思考希特勒统治下发生的事情。到那时，他被视为自俾斯麦以来最伟大的领袖，而希特勒已经淡化为极少数永远不会改变观点的人心中的残余。我想，希特勒的声誉慢慢地——或者说，是慢慢地吗？——变成了我们在节目开头谈到的那个撒旦形象。这是一个过程吗？因为在德国以外，人们理解希特勒的另一个角度是，他是一个荒谬的人物，一个有着小胡子、夸张手势和单侧睾丸的滑稽人物。事实上，希特勒真的只有一个睾丸吗？我想这可能是……又一个传说。又一个传说。不，医疗报告显示他在那方面完全正常。
Yeah, but was it a process? Yeah, well, the Charlie Chaplin caricature, of course, had a big impact in foreign countries and people caricaturing Hitler. You could never in Germany see Hitler as a figure of thumb. Not until very recently, anyway. He was far too malign an individual for that. But there was a sense, I mean, also linking on with what Dominic was asking a few moments ago, there was a sense in the immediate
是的，但这是否是一个过程？是的，查理·卓别林的讽刺画在国外当然产生了很大影响，人们在讽刺希特勒。在德国，你永远不会把希特勒看作一个滑稽人物。至少直到最近才这样。对他来说，他是一个太邪恶的人。但有一种感觉，也就是联系到多米尼克刚才问的问题，在战后初期有一种感觉，
post-war period that Hitler became a sort of alibi for a nation, that you could blame Hitler and his the Nazi leaders for what had gone wrong and not turn too closely to investigate what ordinary people had done in all sorts of walks of life to make this regime function and that was a lengthy process by which people turned their attention away from Hitler to looking at German society itself and seeing why this worked in the way that it did and why Hitler was able to have the impact that he did within Germany. And from the 1960s onwards,
希特勒成为了一个国家的替罪羊，你可以把一切错误归咎于希特勒和纳粹领导人，而不去仔细调查普通人在各行各业中为维持这个政权运作所做的事情。这是一个漫长的过程，人们将注意力从希特勒身上转移到审视德国社会本身，看看为什么它会以这种方式运作，以及为什么希特勒能够在德国产生那样的影响。从20世纪60年代开始，
there was a turn away from, in German historiography, away from the notion that this was Hitler and the Nazis, Nazi leaders who had done this, to looking more widely at various structures of German society which had made this possible. But it was only really in the 1980s that the attention moved in a big way towards looking at the German society more generally. So German social history of the Third Reich was very slow to develop. And
德国史学界出现了一种转变，不再认为这是希特勒和纳粹领导人所为，而是更广泛地审视使这一切成为可能的德国社会结构。但直到20世纪80年代，人们的注意力才真正大规模地转向更广泛的德国社会。因此，第三帝国的德国社会史发展非常缓慢。而且
when I went to Germany, I started working on this in the 1970s, I was in at the infancy of this, I was quite astonished that I was, that how little had been done on the grassroots of Germany at time, but that made big strides forward in the 1980s. And then the next step was that Hitler was reinserted into this picture. So instead of being now either structures of German society or a fixation on Hitler, it became linking Hitler into the structures of German society that have made this possible. I think that's a process that really would have arrived at by the time we got into the 1990s. And then what about this idea of Hitler, the way that Hitler has become this sort of embodiment of evil?
当我20世纪70年代去德国开始研究这个课题时，我正处于这一领域的起步阶段，我非常惊讶于当时对德国基层社会的研究竟然如此之少，但在20世纪80年代取得了巨大的进步。接下来的步骤是将希特勒重新纳入这幅图景中。因此，现在不再是德国社会结构或对希特勒的执着，而是将希特勒与使这一切成为可能的德国社会结构联系起来。我认为这是一个到20世纪90年代我们才真正达到的过程。那么，关于希特勒成为邪恶化身的这种观点呢？
Because that's now the norm, isn't it? I mean, as Tom said right at the beginning of the recording, there's this sort of sense now that Hitler is the enduring benchmark. You know, if you don't like Donald Trump, you compare him with Hitler. If somebody says an opinion you disagree with hitler is the comparison that you kind of dust down do you sort of as a as as the well you know certainly the leading english-speaking expert on on um hitler do you do you wince when you see all this or do you think it has a value as a kind of cautionary tale as a kind of
因为这现在是常态了，不是吗？我的意思是，正如汤姆在录音开始时所说，现在有一种感觉，希特勒是持久的标杆。你知道，如果你不喜欢唐纳德·特朗普，你就把他和希特勒作比较。如果有人发表了你不同意的观点，希特勒就是你拿出来掸掸灰尘进行比较的对象。作为……嗯，当然是英语世界中关于希特勒的首席专家，当你看到这一切时，你会感到畏缩吗？还是你认为它作为一种警示故事，作为一种
political tool turning more towards the former i think i win slightly not because i um have any um truck with anything that hitler ever stood for of course i don't it's absolutely uh the abhorrent an abomination uh but it's it's a very easy device, isn't it, to attack someone with, to link them with Hitler and so on. And in a way, it reminds me, two or three decades ago, anybody whose ideas you disagreed with was called a fascist and so on. And so fascism was then just a catch-all for some political line that was disagreeable. Now Hitler, association with Hitler is a shortcut for some moral despicability on somebody's part. And the moral despicability needs to be assessed in its own right,
政治工具是有价值的？我更倾向于前者，我想我会稍微畏缩一下，不是因为我认同希特勒所代表的任何东西，当然我不认同，这绝对是令人憎恶的，是一种罪恶。但这是一种非常简单的攻击手段，不是吗？把某人与希特勒联系起来等等。在某种程度上，这让我想起二三十年前，任何你不同意其观点的人都会被称为法西斯等等。所以法西斯主义当时只是一个用来形容令人不快的政治路线的万能词。现在，与希特勒的联系成了某人道德卑劣的捷径。而道德卑劣需要根据其自身情况进行评估，
not by just turning to blame Hitler for all this. And so it's a very easy resort. And Hitler was absolutely a terrible figure. Perhaps the dominant, in terms of his impact, you could argue that he's the most significant figure in the first half of the 20th century. But there were others as well, of course. And you don't need to stop at Hitler to look for malign figures.
而不是仅仅转而把这一切归咎于希特勒。所以这是一种非常简单的诉诸手段。希特勒绝对是一个可怕的人物。也许从他的影响来看，你可以说他是20世纪上半叶最重要的人物。但当然还有其他人。你不需要只盯着希特勒去寻找邪恶人物。
And not just Stalin either, but many others, Mao Zedong too and many of them. So it's because we've concentrated so much on Germany and Germany is fairly close to us and it's a society we understand and we have a lot of dealings with. We focus much more on that. And we were actually involved in a war against this country not that long ago. And the Second World War has become the central point of British post-war mythology, I think. So in all these ways, Hitler has become then the central figure of political evil. And it's a very easy move then to use that to associate Hitler with anybody else who's used repulsive views or whatever we disagree now and want to highlight. Turning that on its head, we have a question from Peter Evans, who asks, so many figures from the past who committed atrocious acts of mass murder
也不仅仅是斯大林，还有许多其他人，毛泽东也是，还有很多。所以这是因为我们太关注德国了，德国离我们很近，是我们了解并且有很多往来的社会。我们更关注这一点。而且不久前我们还参与了针对这个国家的战争。我认为第二次世界大战已经成为英国战后神话的核心点。所以从所有这些方面来看，希特勒已经成为政治邪恶的核心人物。那么，利用这一点将希特勒与任何其他持有令人反感的观点或我们现在不同意并想要强调的人联系起来，是非常容易的。反过来说，我们有一个来自彼得·埃文斯的问题，他问，过去许多犯下大规模谋杀
and genocide, and he cites Julius Caesar and Genghis Khan, seem eventually to be rehabilitated, their crimes excused or forgotten. Will that happen to Hitler in, say, 200 years or 500 years? We won't be around to see what happens in 200 or 500 years, so I don't know the answer to that question. But I could imagine that, just for the sake of argument, I could imagine in 1,000 years that Hitler will be one figure whose absolutely horrific acts are then relativised. As you mentioned Genghis Khan, I think, a little while ago,
和种族灭绝暴行的历史人物，他提到了尤利乌斯·凯撒和成吉思汗，似乎最终都被平反了，他们的罪行被原谅或遗忘了。希特勒在200年或500年后会发生这种情况吗？我们活不到200年或500年后去见证会发生什么，所以我不知道这个问题的答案。但我可以想象，仅仅为了论证，我可以想象在1000年后，希特勒将成为一个其绝对恐怖的行为被相对化的人物。正如你刚才提到的成吉思汗，我想，不久前，
and one Swiss writer, Burkhardt, a cultural historian, actually writing about historical greatness, singled out Genghis Khan as a great leader. We think of him now in terms of the horrors that he perpetrated. But it's very much how we look on these characters morally. And I don't think many people today are very preoccupied by the morality of Genghis Khan. But Hitler is very close to our time, so we are preoccupied with him.
一位瑞士作家布克哈特，一位文化历史学家，在撰写关于历史伟人时，特别提到了成吉思汗是一位伟大的领袖。我们现在从他所犯下的恐怖罪行来思考他。但这很大程度上取决于我们如何从道德上看待这些人物。我不认为今天有很多人非常关心成吉思汗的道德问题。但希特勒离我们的时代很近，所以我们很关心他。
How it will be in 500 or 1,000 years, I don't know. But I could imagine that there'll be other monsters that come along in the meanwhile, and we're more preoccupied with them than we are with Hitler. Yeah, so Hitler's sort of status, he won't, I mean, Tom and I have talked before in this podcast, we've been talking about morality and history, the way in which the Nazis have become this sort of moral benchmark.
500年或1000年后会怎样，我不知道。但我可以想象，在此期间会出现其他怪物，我们对他们的关注会超过对希特勒的关注。是的，所以希特勒的地位，他不会……我的意思是，汤姆和我之前在这个播客中谈过，我们一直在谈论道德和历史，纳粹已经成为这种道德标杆的方式。
But you don't think that will endure. I mean, so that will have a shelf life as the Second World War recedes into history, do you think? And we will develop new kind of quasi-religious figures to judge politicians against. I think for the absolutely foreseeable future, we will continue to see that as the benchmark of political evil, and quite rightly so. But how that will materialise over a lengthy period of time is impossible for us to say. And I can just imagine at any rate that that will be relativised then.
但你不认为这会持续下去。我的意思是，随着第二次世界大战淡出历史，这会有保质期吗？我们是否会发展出新的准宗教人物来评判政治家？我认为在绝对可预见的未来，我们将继续把这视为政治邪恶的标杆，而且理应如此。但这种情况在很长一段时间内会如何演变，我们无法说。无论如何，我只能想象它到那时会被相对化。
Practically everything in history is relativised. I mean, when you think of the legacy of political leaders, however great those leaders have been seen in their own time, the legacy tends to fade. And maybe it's only a small number of religious leaders whose legacy has been impermeable over the centuries. So I think there probably will be some way in which that is no longer the sole or the leading benchmark of evil. But I think that sort of speculative question is one that historians can't really answer and nor can anybody else for that matter. I think leaving the episode on a question
历史上几乎所有事物都会被相对化。我的意思是，当你想到政治领袖的遗产时，无论这些领袖在他们那个时代被认为多么伟大，遗产往往会褪色。也许只有少数宗教领袖的遗产在几个世纪里是不可磨灭的。所以我认为可能确实会有某种方式，使其不再是唯一或主要的邪恶标杆。但我认为这种推测性的问题是历史学家无法真正回答的，其他人也一样。我认为以一个
that historians, even you, Sir Ian, cannot answer is perhaps the best note to end this absolute tour de force. I can't thank you enough. And Les Dominic, you have any final questions? I think we should. Sirian has performed manfully and I think he probably has long overdue for arrest.
连历史学家，甚至是你，伊恩爵士，都无法回答的问题来结束这一集，也许是结束这场绝对精彩的演讲的最佳方式。我怎么感谢你都不为过。多米尼克，你还有什么最后的问题吗？我想我们应该结束了。伊恩爵士表现得非常出色，我想他可能早就该休息了。
It's been very enjoyable talking to you both anyway. And thank you very much for the questions and for the people who sent the questions in. Yeah, some fantastic questions this week and even better answers, of course. Tom, it's such an interesting subject, isn't it? I mean, it seems so familiar because Hitler is sort of so deeply embedded in the contemporary imagination. And I mean, we've talked so much about this idea of Hitler as the devil, you know, which we're all so familiar with.
无论如何，和你们俩交谈非常愉快。非常感谢你们的问题，也感谢那些寄来问题的人。是的，这周有一些很棒的问题，当然还有更好的答案。汤姆，这是一个非常有趣的话题，不是吗？我的意思是，它看起来很熟悉，因为希特勒在当代人的想象中根深蒂固。我的意思是，我们谈论了很多关于希特勒作为魔鬼的这种想法，你知道，我们对此都很熟悉。
Well, I mean, you in your book on Christianity, I mean, this is your first chance to plug Christianity. Two whole episodes of that. Thank you, Dominic. Yeah, you'll have to forgive him, Sir Ian. Sorry about this. But you sort of tee up Hitler, don't you, as the ultimate anti-Christian figure. And do you think he'll be with us in that respect? So what these two episodes have been about is a great historian, kind of paint stripping myth to show us the reality, to show us the man. But I think that the myth has become a crucially significant fact of history in itself. So the myths that people believe of Hitler, the sense they have of him as the essence of evil, in a sense, he's become a theological figure i think
嗯，我的意思是，你在关于基督教的书中，这是你第一次为基督教做广告。整整两集。谢谢你，多米尼克。是的，伊恩爵士，你得原谅他。对此我很抱歉。但你把希特勒塑造成了终极的反基督教人物，不是吗？你认为他在那方面会一直伴随着我们吗？所以这两集的内容是一位伟大的历史学家，剥去神话的外衣向我们展示现实，向我们展示那个人。但我认为神话本身已经成为历史中一个至关重要的事实。所以人们相信的关于希特勒的神话，他们认为他是邪恶本质的感觉，在某种意义上，我认为他已经成为一个神学人物。
so i think he's replaced the devil in our imaginings and i've said you know auschwitz is hell um the horrors that the nazis and ultimately hitler brought about you know that that that in the imaginings of people has replaced the kind of Christian mythology and it's become a new mythology. And so in a sense, the relationship of Hitler to the horrors that he unleashed prompts all kinds of theological questions about responsibility, about the nature of evil, about our potential for evil. Is there a Hitler within us? Is there a Hitler constantly waiting us is there a hitler constantly waiting within our societies to take over i think these are ultimately theological rather than political anxieties yeah i mean i think that's a good note on which to end actually the idea
所以我认为他取代了我们想象中的魔鬼，我说过，你知道，奥斯威辛就是地狱，纳粹和最终希特勒带来的恐怖，你知道，在人们的想象中，这已经取代了基督教神话，并成为了一种新的神话。因此，在某种意义上，希特勒与他所释放的恐怖之间的关系引发了各种关于责任、关于邪恶本质、关于我们潜在邪恶的神学问题。我们内心深处有一个希特勒吗？有一个希特勒在不断等待着我们吗？有一个希特勒在我们的社会中不断等待着接管吗？我认为这些最终是神学上的焦虑，而不是政治上的焦虑。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个很好的结束语，实际上，这个想法
you know hitler is not somebody outside ourselves who is the incarnation of evil i mean he's actually in us um very sort of william golding ish uh point he is golem he's actually in us. Very sort of William Golding-ish point. He is Gollum. We're all got potential. Anyway, that's very... Once again, I've managed to dumb it down right at the end, which is kind of what I think... Well done, Dominic. It's what listeners kind of expect, isn't it? Anyway, Sir Ian, thank you so much
你知道，希特勒不是我们之外的某个邪恶化身，我的意思是，他实际上就在我们心中，非常像威廉·戈尔丁的观点，他是咕噜，他实际上就在我们心中。非常像威廉·戈尔丁的观点。他是咕噜。我们都有潜力。总之，这非常……再一次，我在最后把它简化了，我想这就是……干得好，多米尼克。这就是听众所期待的，不是吗？总之，伊恩爵士，非常感谢你
for coming on the podcast. It's been fantastic to have you, and we will be back next week. Goodbye. Bye. Goodbye. our view and uh we will be back next week goodbye bye goodbye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please sign up up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来到这个播客。有你参加真是太棒了，我们下周会回来。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。即 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。